years of indiscriminate attacks
civilian hospitals schools and markets
targeted
mounting evidence of war crimes
but images like these gathered by sky
news's alex crawford
and her team in northwestern syria could
be used by the united nations
to aid eventual prosecutions there's a
board of inquiries set up by the un
to investigate why these strikes are
happening on hospitals which are
protected
by the geneva conventions if you were
willing to give your footage to the
board of inquiry
that might be one small thing that could
be done that's audio we've tracked down
from the cockpit
of a russian jet i looked through these
images
taken on monday with justin bronk a
weapons expert
we think a multiple strikes
all in one go maybe three four strikes
were seen
hitting this hospital which was the main
the main hospital serving tens of
thousands of people
in this area these sort of pictures uh
are a useful piece of the puzzle for
investigators trying to put together a
case to show exactly what did happen
the damage that you see here would be
consistent with
two or three 500-pound class bomb
impacts uh
so from a a jet fighter would be a
standard uh
carrier for that sort of payload um
notable that they're
they're talking about three uh strikes
on the same building
so that was just a reasonable degree of
precision
again potentially with either a
targeting port or quite an advanced jet
which would point towards russia rather
than the syrian air force which
has been reduced to mostly unguided
weapon deliveries
this is an air strike on a house
belonging to a pensioner
certainly what we've seen from the
russian air campaign and the syrian
government
campaign uh over the past five or six
years is a consistent effort to
not only terrorize areas held by rebel
groups
but which civilians are of course living
in as well but actually to deliberately
depopulate those areas
these pictures are from an attack in
march
2018 against um a damascus suburb of
ghouta
using chemical weapons as well as uh
sort of conventional bombardment
is just another way to drive the
population out of those rebel-held areas
in syria no one is safe even journalists
in the firing line russia
backs the regime of syrian president
bashar al-assad
but it denies hitting civilian targets
the chance is slim of moscow or
any party to this conflict facing an
international tribunal over alleged war
crimes
but while journalists and civilians are
still able
to document this tragedy all hope is not
lost
debra haines sky news